what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime opera and today i will be breaking
down the latest twists
and turns in the bokudo hero story
including the very clear message that
deku
is going to slowly kill himself if he
doesn't change his strategy of trying to
save
everyone at all cost deku's character
has many positive traits
but his obsession with sacrificing his
own body to protect everyone else
is the one thing that could lead to his
tragic downfall
there is a lot to talk about on this
topic so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to animeopro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications with the way that youtube
works now the only way to really make
sure that you're gonna get notified
is to subscribe hit the bell and then
select that option that says
all you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram
at anime uproar finally this video will
of course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned as the search for all for
one continues
endeavour calls deku and tells them that
there's been a change of plans
some time has clearly passed since deku
abandoned all might in his bento box in
the previous chapter
although we are not sure exactly how
much time but
it seems that ever since the events of
the last chapter deku has been going
all out in fighting the villains because
of the absolutely chaotic situation on
the streets of japan
deku has been fighting constantly
without taking any time to recover
or nurse his wounds he is pushing his
body beyond its limits and everyone is
seriously worried
about him endeavour tells deku that the
japanese heroes are about to get some
backup from international heroes
meaning that deku will finally be able
to take a break
endeavor reminds deku that he is the key
to everything
he is the one that all for one wants to
get his hands on
so it is absolutely unacceptable to have
deku
die on them they need deku but we all
know what
deku is like we know him as a person and
we know that he will never just
take a break when he knows that innocent
civilians are suffering
and that brings us to a very serious
problem
with deku's personality a problem that
could bring about his tragic
end we know that deku doesn't want to
kill anyone not even villains
and he wants to save everyone that's his
whole thing
however the manga has already pointed
out on numerous occasions
that in his rush to save others deku
often neglects his own
health and safety he will go to any
lengths to be heroic he will push his
body beyond its limits
over and over again and eventually that
heroism
could be the very thing that kills him
this idea
is very much stressed yet again in the
latest chapter
and it's something that we have to pay
close attention to
in the end deku's worst enemy may not be
any villain
at all he may end up being his own worst
enemy
yes what deku is doing is noble and
heroic
but if he ends up destroying himself and
his own body in the process
of trying to be a hero and save everyone
he won't be able to save anyone anymore
although by acting this way deku is
definitely going to earn
the respect of stain and you just know
that stain is still out there lurking
and watching all of these events unfold
as you probably guessed deck who tells
endeavor that he cannot give the
villains time to prepare so he won't
take breaks and he will continue to
fight even the vestiges of the former
one for all users
are urging deku to chill out and take
some time to allow his wounds to heal
but deku seems to ignore them as well
danger sense tells him that there is a
threat nearby
and he rushes off to meet it the
situation is getting so bad
that the vestiges decide to call a
meeting amongst themselves
in order to discuss deku's situation
everyone is seated down in a chair
except for the second user who is still
standing off to the side
presumably the second user still hasn't
fully come around to everyone else's
plan
but he is certainly more willing to
engage than he was before
and while all of the other vestiges are
worried about deku pushing himself
too hard the second user believes that
deku is actually
on the right path in this time of
extreme crisis
deku has a duty to keep pushing himself
in order to save the
innocent nevertheless the second user
believes that there is something that
the vestiges
can do to help protect deku
but we don't get to find out what that
thing is
because the focus of the chapter then
shifts to deku fighting a bunch of
villains
in the real world the regular people on
the streets are actually freaked out by
deku when they first
see him both because of his new darker
appearance and because of the fact that
he is clearly using
multiple quirks the people are worried
that deku might be one of all for one's
subordinates
but he assures them that he is not and
of course his actions clearly
demonstrate that he is no
villain he is going out of his way to
protect civilians from the villains
but he just isn't doing it through the
official pro hero system
throughout it all deku is being driven
by the strong desire to find all for one
and the league of villains and to stop
them from causing more harm to the
people of japan
by the way the deku keeps talking about
needing to find them
and needing to stop them it seems as if
this might be turning into a bit of an
obsession
deku continues to take on more and more
strong villains
all the while thinking about all the
people in his life that he needs to
protect
all of the people that he wants to spare
from living a life of fear
and suffering this includes his mother
gran torino
all might izawa eddie and of course all
of his fellow hero
students and classmates deck who wants
so desperately to be able to smile with
all of them again
he wants all the innocent people of
japan to be able to smile again
and that is what's driving him forward
despite the exhaustion
and despite all the injuries but at the
end of the day
deku is still human and as humans there
is only so far that we can push
ourselves before our bodies just
give out and unfortunately deku
may be reaching that point he may be
slowly killing himself right in front of
our eyes
the next thing we know deku finds
himself in the middle of the city square
where
almighty's famous statue is located the
statue that now reads
i am not here around the statue we can
see that multiple city buildings have
been damaged and some of them are
straight up lying in ruins
which means that this place is no
stranger to villain activity
inside the square itself deku comes
across
yet another villain assassin and
tartarus skp
sent by all for one this assassin's name
is dictator
and he has literally the perfect quirk
for defeating someone like deku his
quirk
allows him to take possession of a bunch
of innocent people and control their
bodies
against their will as such he is able to
use these civilians as
human shields while also sending some of
them to attack
deku since deku's top priority is
protecting civilians
he has to avoid hurting them and this
gives dictator
a massive advantage thankfully deku
already knows about dictator
and his quirk the only way to break the
villain's control over the civilians
is either to hit the civilians with a
large shock or to knock out the villain
himself
since deck who doesn't want to hurt the
civilians his only option is to find a
way to knock
out the villain but deku is then swarmed
by the civilians who were sent to attack
him against their will
and in a very bizarre and scary moment
they begin apologizing while hitting him
it almost looks like some sort of
strange
zombie apocalypse and as deku's mask is
being pulled from his face
his eyes seem so exhausted and just kind
of empty
he tells the civilians that he knows
what's going on and he promises to free
them and find a solution
to this situation but you can tell by
the look in his eyes that deku
is on the brink of collapse he's just
been through so much
he's exhausted every ounce of his energy
and yet the villains just keep coming
and to make things worse
they keep putting innocent civilians in
danger it isn't looking good for deku
at this point and it really looks like
the civilians are about to dog-pile him
to death
but then out of nowhere bakugou shows up
and fires off an ap
shot directly into dictator as bakugo
says
i found him guys it is implied that this
was what the second one for all user had
in mind when he said that there's
something that they can do
to help deku this is also the end of the
chapter
but what does this all mean did the
vestiges somehow
contact bakugo and tell him to come and
help deku
does the second user have some sort of
connection to bakugou
this is where all those crazy theories
about the second user being bakugo from
the future or an ancestor of bakugou
are going to kick into high gear or
was this maybe related to the second
movie where bakugo was briefly able to
use
one for all something that up to this
point most of us assumed
wasn't really canon if bakugo really did
have
one for all within him even briefly then
presumably the vestiges could make
contact with him
in some way but again that is a big if
because that event in the movie was
highly unusual and it didn't seem to fit
within the established one for all
canon or perhaps this was all just
symbolic
maybe the second user's point was that
in order to help deku they need to
convince him to accept the help of
others
including his friends and classmates and
then bakugou just happened to show up
when his friend needed him which
underscores
the second user's point i'm not sure
what exactly happened here we'll have to
wait for the future chapters
but definitely let me know what you guys
think down in the comments below
how did bakugo find deku and who was he
talking to when he said i found him guys
was he somehow talking to the vestiges
directly or was he just talking to other
people who might have come with him like
maybe the other class 1a students
all in all this chapter had a very clear
message
and that message was that deku is slowly
killing himself by trying to protect
everyone
on his own this is a trait that he has
demonstrated several times before
and it is probably his single biggest
weakness
if anything brings deku down it won't be
a villain
it will be his willingness to neglect
his own well-being for the sake of
helping others
and bakugou showing up at the end of the
chapter is an indication that deku needs
to accept help from others
including his friends and classmates up
to this point
deku was trying his best to protect them
all by separating himself
from them since he is the main target of
the villains he didn't want his friends
to get caught in the crossfire
so he decided to try to do everything on
his own he decided to take on
all the risk and all the responsibility
in order to spare
everyone else but we all know that
bakugou doesn't like playing the side
character while deku plays protagonist
and realistically all of dekku's friends
want to be there for him
and help him after all they are all
heroes in training they all want to do
the right thing and help the innocent
so they're not about to sit back and let
deku sacrifice himself
for them the previous chapter included
that very symbolic scene of deku leaving
all might behind
as a way to protect him and a while ago
we know that deku left the ua
in order to protect everyone there but
as endeavour and the vestiges have made
clear
deku also needs protection he can't do
everything on his own even though he
clearly wants to
and if he keeps trying he will end up
killing himself before he ever gets a
chance to defeat the villains
this chapter is clearly telling us that
deku needs to learn to be a
team player he needs to stop obsessing
over protecting everyone else
and he needs to accept the help of
others yes
helping deku might put those others in
danger but they all want to be heroes
that is what they signed up for as
strong as deku
is and as committed as he is to heroics
he cannot
do this alone and that is an important
life lesson that he needs to learn
right now if bakugo hadn't showed up
when he did
deku may have been stomped to death by
the very civilians he was trying to
protect those civilians were under the
control of a villain
and knowing deku he would not have
fought back against him because they are
innocent
and as exhausted as he was already he
could have been seriously injured or
even killed
in this situation thankfully bakugou
showed up to save the day
but if deku keeps working alone there
may not be anyone to show up next time
this means that if he wants to keep
being a hero and saving people in the
long term
deku needs to change his strategy so do
you guys think that deku is going to
accept help
from his classmates is he going to start
fighting alongside them
or is he going to keep trying to do it
all by himself in order to protect his
classmates from potential danger
maybe the smartest move that deku could
make is to start working together with
stain
we know that stain is not necessarily a
nice guy anyway
so deku won't feel guilty if stain puts
himself in danger by fighting alongside
deku
and knowing stain and his ideology i
really feel like he supports
deku respects deku and will end up
fighting
on his side i definitely want to see
that happen
and now the story seems to be giving us
a good reason for why
it might happen so i'm definitely
excited about that
realistically in the long term deku will
have to learn to work together with all
of his fellow heroes and hero students
because as strong as he is and he is
really strong
all for one and the awakened shigaraki
are not the types of villains that
anyone could defeat
on their own let me know what you guys
thought about this chapter down in the
comments
and also let me know what type of
international heroes do you expect to
see coming to japan to back up the
japanese heroes
are we going to see characters from the
movies like maybe melissa are we going
to see brand new heroes we've never seen
before
let me know down below if you enjoyed
this boku no hero video and you want to
see more in the future
please leave that like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you really have to go through the
trouble of subscribing hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he's an
absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
algertol dr cortman the toasted chee the
spike emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody hebert
and monkey d
quilly and of course i want to thank our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only gilgamesh the red-haired raven
angel cruz anatoly kazatsuki very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks hinokamian
water joanne garcia ted noted fat boy
games corey mcgowan metal mama deadly
saint and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you